from the Woodrow Wilson Center in
Washington DC mr. sell discusses his new
book slobodan milosevic
and the destruction of Yugoslavia which
covers both sides of the wars in
Slovenia and Croatia Bosnia and Kosovo
the program runs an hour and 25 minutes
well we might as well begin work close
to 11 o'clock
welcome to the Woodrow Wilson Center
today we are honored to have a book
launch in seminar by a fairly recent
fellow of ours
Lewis Cell who has just published a book
that he worked on or started working on
when he was a fellow here in 1998 $2.99
on slobodan milosevic and the
destruction of Yugoslavia I'll show you
what it looks like and if any of you are
interested I think you probably noticed
the books are on sale out in the hall
outside Duke University Press it's
needless to say even given our engaged
status here it's an excellent book reads
very well provides a unique focus I
think on Milosevic himself the man and
the politician in his role in Yugoslavia
that you probably will not get from some
of the other books that are out there as
Louis I think embodies the Wilson ideal
that we talk so much about here at the
center and that he combines experience
and distinguished experience of that in
the world of policy and international
affairs with scholarship prior to coming
here he had a very distinguished career
in the Foreign Service and spent about
eight years on the ground between 1974 I
believe it was in 2000 in Yugoslavia so
he knows aware of he speaks he spent
about three years I think in Zagreb as
council in 1974 76 he returned to
Yugoslavia as the political counselor
and there our embassy in Belgrade just
in time for the rise of Milosevic 1987
through 91 where he witnessed the
consolidation of Milosevic and power
and we're I dare say one of the
highlights of his stay there was my
visit in 1998 when I came as a
representative of Congress let's say and
he took me to novice odd to personally
witness some of these so-called
manifestations and mass demonstrations
and all these thoughts so I myself got a
chance to see this this at work he then
returned to the State Department and
needed some rest and relaxation so I
believe they sent them to Moscow for a
while and after that he was in the
Bureau of an INR at state and then he
sort of capped his career as the
political adviser to the first in of the
international community's high
representatives for the bosnian peace
process
former swedish prime minister Carl Bildt
in 1994-95 at which point he was
participated in the Dayton peace process
as well as able to see on the ground
some of the misery and that surrounded
the situation that sorry of all at the
end of the war and he was here from 19
1998 to 99 and he retired and he's been
up at in Maine in retirement but
teaching at the University of Maine and
also keeping very involved in affairs of
the region through his association with
the International Crisis Group where he
was a representative in pristine and for
several months in 2000 and was there
again just last month and that's why we
have entitled this not the title this
session not just the title of his book
but Milosevic from Kosovo to the Hague
because Luis will relate his work on the
book to the situation going on in the
Hague and in Kosovo at large and so I
think that's enough from me little Louis
will talk for about 30 to 40 minutes and
then hopefully we'll have another 30
minutes or so for questions and we'll
end this session slightly before 12:30
to enable him to get off to his next
appointment
and Marty yeah thank you very much for
that kind introduction
what what you what you outlined was the
fact that throughout I spent mine and my
definitely a career attending to to
focus on countries which ceased to exist
either shortly after I arrived or
shortly after I left
whether that's coincidental or not some
people have wondered I also I do see out
in the audience here some some partners
in that and though that enterprise and I
very I'm very glad to do to see all of
you here and thank you very much for
coming what I'd like to do is I will I
will focus on slobodan milosevic
his career and all's and and in the
course of doing that also the importance
of Kosovo to that and I think what I'll
do is to the question-and-answer period
if anybody has any any questions about
the situation current situation in
Kosovo and deal with that in the
question and answer period just to keep
it down to a manageable length well with
that let me let me get underway as Marty
indicated and I'm sure everyone here is
aware slobodan milosevic is now on trial
in The Hague for for war crimes
including the crime of genocide he's the
first head of state to be so indicted
for war crimes and it's just truly a
revolutionary and a very important act
the trial which began in early February
supposed to last the said that will last
up to two years that hundreds of
witnesses will be called Milosevic
although rejecting cooperation with the
court challenging the courts legitimacy
is defending himself and defending
himself with great vigor and skill I
would say
a very aggressive defense is anyone who
knows Milosevic would expect he is he's
a music is a very dangerous antagonist
he's no knoweth no time more dangerous
than when he's cornered and I think I
think he remains capable even now of
great mischief and possibly worse what
what I'm gonna talk about today and in
some way what what the book is about is
how slobodan milosevic
this this man who in the beginning of
his career seemed to be a very ordinary
communist apparatchik he was his
nickname I don't know if this was said
to his face but his nickname in the
early 80s is said to be little Lenin yet
he came to power this man he came to
power through a there's a lot of
paradoxes about Milosevic although he
started out as a communist he came to
power on a wave of nationalist euphoria
wave of national shoe foria which he
partly helped to create although he
wasn't only responsible for it yet
Milosevic has always denied being a
nationalist and I honestly think that in
some Kate way that's true that for
Milosevic nationalism was a tool
nationalism was a vehicle that he used
to gain power to gain his object some
objectives and something he had be
discarded although our least tried to
discard later when it became no longer
useful and then toward the end of his
career again took it up maybe when that
was the only thing left to him Slobodan
Milosevic
is at least in my view truly a war
criminal Reese truly responsible for the
deaths
of thousands and hundred tens of
thousands of people and more yet he
never killed anyone
that's very clear himself and he made it
may well be true that he never even
signed any orders directly or during
that there's been as great searched for
years for The Smoking Gun through
intelligence sources through the Hague
sources and some of which I'm privy to
some of which I've not I mean as far as
I'm aware no one has ever come up with
that smoking gun the piece of paper or
the transcript of the phone conversation
which Moz which orders someone to go out
and do something criminal nevertheless
he was he he was truly responsible for
the for the policies for the actions
which caused this untold misery
throughout the Balkans the in the course
of this slobodan milosevic
this man who was who is now on the DA
and the dock in the hague found himself
at the center of world diplomacy for
several years he was courted by a steady
stream of diplomats a steady stream of
presidents and prime ministers he found
himself at the center of the piece prof
peace process it shows another exam an
who is he's capable of reinventing
himself when if faced with with a
setback faced with a problem as often
all too often happened for he led his
country into disaster after disaster he
would regroup come up with something new
and often in the process of reinventing
himself as something new after Dayton
Montalbano Milosevic was congratulated
by President Clinton and by others by
President Chirac of France and others
for his contribution and he did make a
contribution to sign it to Dayton in
some ways that probably couldn't have
happened without him at least not in the
way it did happen
so there's a lot of paradoxes out there
about this man and I'm gonna what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna try to just discuss
briefly a few a few snapshots of
incidents through his life which I think
illustrate elements of his personality
illustrate features of his role in the
Balkans and in world affairs and and
then throw it open to questions I'll
start with the first the first event the
first snapshot cost of Apulia April 24
1987 Kosovo Polje is one of the centers
of Serb population in in Kosovo
an angry crowd of Serbs several thousand
Serbs had gathered in Kosovo polla
claiming to be the victims of a
persecution and mistreatment by the
majority Albanian population I think
there was some truth to that
although exaggerated but I think they
did suffer some discrimination and
sometimes worse and in case this
demonstration which was pre-planned the
call went up to Belgrade to send
somebody down to deal with it
the man who was the leader of Serbia at
the time Evon stumble each to his so
much to his subsequent regret declined
the invitation and since slow and I'm a
loss of itch instead Milosevic had been
stomp Alicia's protege ever since
University for the preceding 15 years or
so
Milosevic had basically been Tom leach
his right-hand man had risen steadily
through the ranks of the Yugoslav
burocracy Istanbul each did so assembly
symbol ostrich down Milosevic I think
was genuinely shocked by what he saw by
this crowd he was surprised I've talked
to people who were there with him eyes
and velocity the young kosovo albanians
leader of the car of the leaf communist
party was there at the time with him
describes Milosevic really kind of
shocked and all and frightened almost
paralyzed he he had to Milan velocity at
least says that he had
put small push Milosevic to that to the
window when you got a deal with these
people there they were pelting the
building with stones and they threatened
they get out of hand and and I mean he
Milosevic when when he was forced to he
actually did so and he did so in a
brilliant fashion he he he went out and
spoke to the people he uttered these
words to the police the police of course
wrought hand the Yugoslavs police
preferred method of riot control was the
rubber rubber baton or worse and they
were certainly quite ready to use that
on this crowd and Milosevic entered
these words that no one will beat this
people anymore or something to that
effect it remains a little bit unclear
exactly what he said and then he then he
invited the people into the building and
sat through the session lasts all night
listening to grievances from the people
and at the end stood up and and gave a
speech
extemporizing largely in which he he
sort of he urged the people of the
survey people of Kosovo to remain to
stay in Kosovo this was the homeland of
the Serbian nation urged him to stay and
not leave as they were threatening that
night I think was a ruse it was a
breakthrough from a loss of hitch he who
had been as I said earlier and not noted
for nothing but as much as as a as a
loyal and dutiful apparatchik he
discovered two things that night he
discovered the power of nationalism to
move people this is after all it's 1987
communism in Yugoslavia it had it was
its own distinctive form of communism
but it like communism elsewhere in
Eastern Europe was starting to lose its
hold starting to lose its ability to to
move people and Milosevic discovered the
power of nationalism to move people the
power of nationalism as an alternative
to the communism and you discover
another thing and that was the power of
his own words I mean he proved nothing
no one would have predicted in advance
he proved to be a brilliant speaker at
least in this phase of his life he had a
very simple direct style of speech
he spoke to the people in language they
can understand which was quite different
from the from the first stilted
convoluted style of Yugoslavia chol
discourse up to that time and he used
that with with enormous power basically
to unseat stumble each a few months
later and to take supreme power in in
cotton Serbia through a wave of
manipulating the media and a wave of
demonstrations so that's one one
incident let me then fast-forward to
crossover polla again same place June 28
1989 it's two years later a little more
than two years later this time milazzo
which is speaking at the site of the the
cost of a polio battle it's a six
hundredth anniversary of the defeat of
Serbian forces by the invading Turkish
forces when the Serbs are an unusual
people in many ways one of which is that
they they celebrate their as their
national holiday their greatest national
defeat it's as if the American National
Day was Pearl Harbor and I mean it says
a lot about the Serbs I'm not quite sure
what it says but it's quite it's quite
unique and important melosa victims
they're speaking at the six hundredth
anniversary of this battle that had been
a very eventful two years he hits this I
said stimulated this wave of nationalist
demonstrations he had overthrown
basically the legitimate governments of
four of the of the eight Yugoslavia
publics Yugoslavia was divided into
eight more or less federal units
although two of them were autonomous
provinces but they more or less function
as Republic's Milazzo Fitch controlled
four of the eight including Kosovo he
had suppressed coastal autonomy by force
and by by coercion and then all this in
pursuit of what at this point was his
objective I believe what I write he
wanted to rule all of Yugoslavia
he wanted to be a new Tito and he came
close had he won one more republic and
he got in five of the eight republics he
probably he could have controlled the
the presidency which in effect
controlled the army controlled the
particular police and he might have he
might have he might have succeeded when
he failed
excuse me failed I think and it and it
and this failure could have been
predicted because it was it was
obviously impossible to take over
Yugoslavia Slavia relying on served
nationalism as your vehicle I mean the
Serbs were the most numerous people in
the in the Yugoslavia but they only
constituted something like thirty six
percent and by using Serb nationalism as
his vehicle he he helped create
countervailing nationalisms in other
parts of Yugoslavia including including
Croatia from including Bosnia so the
loss of it if he quickly became clear
had failed at the the it also becoming
it was by then clear that things were
getting dangerous so there had been
peaceful so far by and large one of the
one of the upheavals was called the
yoghurt revolution Milosevic overturned
in his crowd a mob of Milosevic
supporters overturned the governor of
voivod inna and one of the things that
the people threw they raided a near a
dairy store and threw packages of
yoghurt at the communist party
headquarters and so that took the name
of the yoghurt revolution that was
peaceful it got worse it got a lot worse
and it got worse quickly an awesome at
his speech was very interesting I was
there I heard it and people had to wait
hours in this sweltering Sun there there
were probably a million people standing
in there in this field
crowd size is an in
and it's not an exact science but there
were a lot of Serbs there and they would
come to hear Milosevic they were
shouting and chanting waving went
banners singing and took him a long time
to come he finally came late arrived by
helicopter and he gave this speech which
in retrospect most of which was probably
written by his wife and it extolled the
virtues of ethnic toleration extolled
the virtues of socialism as a vehicle
for for multi-ethnic cooperation and
this is really not what the crowd wanted
to hear and they had not come to cost of
all this is maybe one eighth of the
population of Serbia and the field and
more since most of them were men maybe a
quarter of the male population of class
Serbia was in that field they did not
want to hear about ethnic cooperation
and the crowd was really getting kind of
restive and finally at the end molester
age brought him to the feet it was to
their feet and he said he toward the end
he said you know we're currently in a in
a phase of conflict these are not armed
conflicts but we cannot exclude that
they'll become armed conflicts and the
crowd went ballistic they went berserk
there was a great roar from a million
people that's just what they wanted to
hear war and he left shortly after that
and then people went home let me but now
that that was 1989 I'm gonna fast
forward now to year two more years to
the summer of 1991 the war that Milazzo
Mitch mentioned in that speech in the
summer of 1991 began in Yugoslavia it
began with a short a small war I mean
small unless I guess you happen to be
one of the victims in Slovenia a
uniquely I think this was one one war
that really slowed and I'm a loss which
was not responsible for instigating and
did not in fact want but it began it
began in Slovenia but it quickly spread
to Croatia throughout that summer of of
1991 served for Serbia regular forces
what we later came to call paramilitary
horses often criminals recruited from
the sort of the lowest dregs of Belgrade
life motivated as much by by loot and
crime as by as by nationalism together
with units of the of the Regular Army
which by that carved out basically a
Serb controlled region about a third of
the population of Croatia which had been
heavily but far from exclusively
populated by Serbs in the process
driving out many of the croatian
inhabitants the this was a pre-planned
operation the the the shape of this plan
was put was started to be put into
effect at least a year earlier what had
happened slow velocity had decided they
had real I realized he could not take
over all of Yugoslavia so he dropped
back to his next plan which was to
create a greater Serbia you can see that
now as we some of the memoir literature
participants have have written about
this we have some of the records you can
see I'm almost where the decision was
made some time early in 1992 basically
to go to create a greater Serbia in the
full knowledge that this would mean
number one the breakup of Yugoslavia and
number two that that would relate to
violence I mean it was clear and anyone
who knew anything about Yugoslavia knew
that the likelihood of a peaceful
separation was very small and indeed
Milosevic never took the path of peace
beginning in the summer of 1990 he and
his and his henchmen started to pump
arms into Croatia and and to a lesser
extent into Bosnia that this was met by
countervailing nationalisms by
countervailing arms from other sides as
well and it was it takes two to tango it
takes two to fight a war and the Croats
in response to this we're also doing
their they did some of their own ethnic
cleansing they did their own army
their own paramilitaries the in the
summer of nineteen news something was
odd there was something odd though about
by Matt Milosevic after the war began
the other thing was he sort of vanished
this man who was a was about at that
point thought of as a charismatic
nationalist a charismatic leader is of
his people of a speaker brilliant
speaker who more or less turned out to
be an absent war leader he seldom if
ever spoke to the people he never made a
speech giving war aims to the Serbian
people describing why what are we
fighting for never did that he never
visited troops at the front or he never
visited wounded soldiers and hospitals
the kind of thing the leaders tend to do
in wartime why one I think because he's
a genuine kind of recluse and control
freak he was really he and his people
his handlers were endlessly afraid of
getting him outside of any kind of
stage-managed situation where things
might get out of control where he
couldn't predict the reaction and and
second he knew I think that that war
those wars were not really popular among
the Serbian people broadly speaking the
the one reason why the the Yugoslav
forces this and the Serbian forces
didn't succeed in the war Croatia was
that when when when serbs by and large
were drafted to fight were mobilized to
fight they deserted on mass it turned
out that there really not a lot of
service which we were willing to die for
this nationalist vision that that
Milosevic was offering them and you know
what happened you had in Croatia and in
Boston followed by Bosnia they served
the Serbs did carve out the Serbs
controlled most of the weapons of the
former Yugoslavia army they carved out
this mini state called the crane and
Croatia they carved out in 1992 a mini
state in Bosnia in which they controlled
roughly 60 or 70 percent of the
territory of Bosnia using the tactics
came to be called ethnic cleansing
violence at civilian population intended
to terrorize people and cause them to
flee and it did it basically began the
process of ethnic sorting out of Bosnia
this provoked countervailing violence
countervailing ethnic cleansing of the
Serbs started it but they weren't the
only the other other other parties
engaged in it as well in response so
that was the situation in 1991-92 I'm
gonna fast forward now to 1995 summer of
1995 that was an incredible incredibly
horrific summer for anyone who lived
through it such things as rubber Nitza
the massacre of several thousand maybe
maybe eight thousand bosnian muslim men
after after after surgeries have fell to
a serving assault a month after that
August of August of 1995 Milazzo Fitch's
world started to collapse around him
around that time up to that time Serbian
forces had been by and large successful
there'd been more or less a stalemate on
the ground but the Serbs controlled most
of the territory they wanted to control
and and they they had they they had that
they were the predominant military force
in August 1995 that started to change
the Croatians who had used the interview
that the three years after a ceasefire
to build up a modern well-equipped army
with with some foreign assistance that
remains the matter there were certainly
weapons from the Germans there was some
assistance from the United States how
much remains a little bit unclear it's
my belief that there was actually very
little military assistance provided to
the Croatian forces by the United State
but there are others who have a
different view in any case the Croatian
forces attacked the Creina
and in a lightning and very quick and
brutal offensive crushed the crane and
driving out all of its Serbian roughly
200,000 Serbian inhabitants fleeing who
fled it was a it was a sight that you
know III witnessed and never expected to
see in the modern world never expected
to see in Europe in the 1990s people
fleeing on in any convenient conveyance
fit all ages men women children babies
old people fleeing and a horse and buggy
on trucks on tractors on foot anything
an entire people migrating across this
lush summer landscape of Serbia this was
a real catastrophe for Milosevic he had
stood by and done nothing to prevent
this and even Milosevic is very
effective propaganda apparatus could not
hide this defeat from the Serbian people
there was a lot of anger in the Serbian
population will have horrid what had
happened there were a lot of people who
blame Milosevic and it didn't stop there
the Croatian and the the Bosnian forces
continued an offensive they didn't stop
at the Crimea they launched they moved
into Bosnia and the bosnian serb forces
were reeling backward there were many
people in that summer and who who
expected that offensive to go all the
way to the drina river - basically - to
drive the serbs completely out of Bosnia
there were some Americans who expected
that I talked to them I was there it
didn't happen and why not what happened
was someone can't well well a lifeline
you know what effect was extended to my
loss salvation who was it well as the it
was the United States for its own good
reasons and in a way
I'm not this is I don't mean this is
necessarily criticism in the summer of
1995 the United States as this was going
on and this was really part of it
amounted a diplomat diplomatic offensive
aimed at bringing a close to the at
bringing a close to the Bosnian conflict
and only the Bosnian conflict the the
clinton ministration which had had not
engaged effectively in in in yugoslavia
for the first three years of its rule in
the summer of 95 saw itself facing a
catastrophe it had been unwilling to and
to commit US troops to for a political
solution in Bosnia yet in the summer of
95 as things like Sri bernisa unfolded
the UN mission in Bosnia was collapsing
it was finished is a UN that Britain
Maine could troop contributors Great
Britain and France had said we are out
of here by the winter if there is no
settlement in the u.s. however had
committed to help get them out there was
a NATO plan for withdrawal of this UN
force which would have been the bigger
the biggest military operation in
Europe's and since World War two
involving up to 30,000 US forces so the
Clinton ministration saw itself
committed to having to head it and
undertaken a commitment to reduce US
forces into Bosnia but only to rescue a
failing UN mission this was a real
prescription for a disaster and and that
provoked a diplomatic intervention which
turned out to be a pretty effective at
ending the war together with military
pressure applied by on the Serbs by this
combined Bosnian Croatian offensive and
by a short NATO bombing campaign and and
slobodan milosevic was really at the
center of this there was a shuttle team
of shuttle diplomacy led a very able
team of US diplomats led by Richard
Holbrooke there was much less noticed
and playing a secondary role a team of
European diplomats led by Carl Bildt
playing a supporting role
I found myself in an odd situation as an
American diplomat as Carl's Gulf deputy
in that in that process in any case you
know Milazzo which was sent her to that
Milosevic was relied upon to deliver the
Bosnian Serbs and did so and it was
relied upon to to basically to be the
guarantor and the the man who made them
who made than a negotiation the deal
possible from the Serbian side and he
did do that the the basic Dayton
compromise came about it took a long
time to get Dayton but there were the
basic Dayton compromise was very simple
and was even agreed before Dayton that
was Bosnia would remain as one state in
other words the Serbs would not be
allowed to break away and from Bosnia
and join Serbia but they were it would
be a very loose state and the Serbs
would have their own ethnically defined
territory within Bosnia and that the
territorial division would be 51% or 49%
for the Serbs and 51% for them for the
crow eat crow Watson and Bosnian Muslims
and that was the outline of the brought
out in the main features of Dayton
Milosevic was was instrumental in that
and causing that to happen together with
with the with us pressure on the Bosnian
Muslim delegation which for a long time
wasn't sure it wanted a deal had had the
it had seen in the summer of 1995 in the
fall of 1995 a vision of maybe
prevailing and and when that when that
vision proved too proved to be
impossible to achieve it took a lot of
persuasion and arm-twisting to get to
get the Bosnian Muslims to go on but
eventually they did let me for the
fast-forward quickly now is it two more
events one now I'm going to move forward
four years to March 1999 Belgrade
the Slovak richard holbrooke who was the
architect of the Dayton Agreement has
been sent
he'd seen Milazzo face repeatedly live
in in the past few weeks and months as
the u.s. re-engaged tried to to broker a
solution to a conflict in Kosovo which
had erupted in 1998 and was getting
worse by the day in the spring of 1999
Milosevic had rejected an international
deal offered to him at the French chalet
of Rambla yay
and and the price for that rejection was
going to be NATO bombing Milus which
knew that and Holbrook has described
seeing Milosevic alone he'd become
almost a recluse by then a very little
active support from the Serbian people
or from anyone else alone in the and the
white palace in Belgrade there's one
last appeal once you sign Milazzo which
says no you know what's gonna happen if
if you don't sign yes says Milosevic I
know you will promise and we did and
eventually and why why was Milosevic so
obdurate what had happened
well the missing the missing element in
cotton and Dayton was was the was the
Kosovo conflict I don't I don't say that
we should that day that cost of Oh
should have been included in the Dayton
settlement but the the critical mistake
was in not turning immediately after
Dayton to address to try and deal with
the BA the cost of a conflict the same
degree of diplomatic and military
intervention resources applied to Kosovo
would have probably could have prevented
that conflict I think why didn't we do
it well we were relying on Milosevic for
to implement the Bosnian peace deal that
we just negotiated there were 30,000
American troops in the initial
contingent that went in to Bosnia and
you know there was a considerable
nervousness in Washington about American
casualties and Milosevic we were relying
on Milosevic
given his word that there wouldn't be
that he would use his influence to
ensure that there were none and he did
and we were relying on him to do that to
relying on him to implement the deal and
you know and when you're doing that when
you're relying on him to implement to
help implement the Dayton Peace
Agreement you're not at the same time in
a very good position to twist his arm on
Kosovo of which by them was his last
achievement the the in 1998 and the in
the fall of 1998 is a u.s. reengaged too
late on Kosovo diplomatically people who
had met Milosevic people in met
Milosevic and date and worked with him
and date and saw him again and his first
words to them he growled this is not
Dayton don't don't think we can you can
do what you did in Dayton this is not
Dayton Kosovo god Kosovo is not dating
Kosovo as my neck he was he was
perfectly willing to give up the Serbs
and in Bosnia and indeed he'd be
perfectly willing to give up the Serbs
in Kosovo for that matter but doing so
would have threatened his whole in power
and that was really what motivated by
then well that was what that was what
motivated him throughout most of his
career eventually he did give in he did
he did have - he did - he did surrender
after a three months NATO bombing
campaign I think he gave in for two
reasons one the threat that the bombing
campaign which really had been not been
us had been had not been an all-out
bombing campaign but but would be there
was a I think he got a credible threat
that he would face much more severe
bombing and and he also got a deal he
thought he got a deal which which
allowed him maybe to hope that he could
somehow retain Kosovo in the future by
virtue of the fact that the UN Security
Council resolution which brought peace
to the region says that Kosovo is
remains a sovereign part of the Federal
Republic of Yugoslavia and the UN on
NATO is the civilian authority
responsible in Kosovo and and the
slavich thought he could count on allies
in the UN to block any decision that
would be uh that he would not like and I
think that's why I agreed to this deal
having having not agreed to something
which was maybe better for him in some
ways earlier last point briefly October
5 2000 a a wave of popular a popular
uprising finally swept most slobodan
milosevic from office tens of thousands
of Serbs on the street demonstrating
that there had been several similar kind
of waves in the future they had all
failed this one succeeded it looked very
much like a spontaneous uprising and in
retrospect it turns out it was not
completely it was it was quite well
planned by the by the Serbian organizers
who and the United States I think behind
the scenes played a significant role the
United States played a role in providing
assistance and guidance to some of those
Serbian organizers as well um the loss
which was swept out of office as crowds
seized the Parliament seized the
television station which was one of the
hated bastions of his rule and then that
evening wanted to move forward there was
a there was that the police had gone I
had gone over to the side of the of the
of the demonstrators although the army
had not there was a group who wanted to
move forward onto Milosevic his house
they were stopped in part by the manner
took over by voice law of course new
needsa what what I have described
and in some sense is the thinking man's
nationalist the you know is also a
believer in legality he he dissuade it
help dissuade the the organizers from
from moving on Milosevic and his family
who were in scon stand the dead inna
suburb of Belgrade that may have been
the right decision because the army was
still its allegiance was a little bit
unclear that night that could there
could have been bloodshed but the unfort
what the unfortunate consequence of that
at least in my view was that what you
have was an arrested revolution it
didn't go all the way and the influence
of Milosevic and his legacy remains in
in too strong in parts of Serbia in the
Army in the police in other in some
other areas as well the there hasn't
been a complete sweeping away of that of
that of that other legacy a complete
willingness to confront the consequence
of the past on whether whether that
happens or means is an open question but
I I think it will and and I think to
conclude with the tribunal I think that
one of the one of the lessons of the
tribunal that we're learning is that I
mean it is good that perpetrators of war
crimes are brought to justice but it's
probably not enough for reconciliation
and I think what is truly needed and for
reconciliation not just in Serbia now
but throughout that region is someway
something like a Truth and
Reconciliation Commission some some way
for all of the peoples of that region to
come together and try to confront the
past and deal honestly with the past and
in order to put that behind them and
deal deal with the future and hopefully
avoid repeating the this tragic these
tragic episodes from the past
so with that I guess I will stop and and
be willing to answer any questions about
what I've said or anything else about
for instance cost and for a
if you wish where I've just come back
from thank you thank you we'll open it
up for questions I guess if you have
some please step to the microphone or if
you're in the middle we'll try to pass
you the microphone
no one's leaping to raise her hand I'd
okay so is John I was gonna ask you
about Kosovo that could wait first John
okay John Lampe from University of
Maryland one of the appreciators of this
project of Lewis's for for quite some
time and so it as timely as The Hague
process goes on indeed that the book
appears and I want to ask about Kosovo
because I'll leave that to Marty but I
will ask about the partly The Hague
process but also The Dispatch of
Milosevic to The Hague because certainly
as we look at public opinion in Belgrade
now it's not going terribly well from
the Western standpoint because the
reinvention as one Belgrad friend friend
said why it seems he's discovered a
career as a lawyer and indeed he is
using the advantage of speaking back to
to Serbia and and not particularly to
the judges so a couple of questions I'm
wondering if you see the prospect of
some of his serve server serbian
lieutenants down the line in the
tribunal as able or ready to speak
because that's going to count with the
serbian public more than any cost of our
albanian however aggrieved and also this
question that I went to Belgrade in fact
we were there together just before he
was he was taken and I went to Belgrade
thinking no no he should stay there and
this process should proceed ahead
criminal proceedings
from what had been done inside Serbia
although I think he may have covered his
financial tracks personally pretty well
too I left thinking that and worrying
that had he stayed in Serbia a judge not
just the jury but Judge and witnesses
would be intimidated in a fashion that
would put any kind of trial in Serbia in
real peril of not being able to reach a
decision so I wanted your thoughts on
first taking him when he was taken and
then now is there some some prospect for
his some of his lieutenants to appear
because I I'm really fearing that for
the Serbian public when you have Zoran
Djindjic joining in the chorus and still
on average to about this is a circus and
these witnesses aren't credible I think
some of the albanian ones absolutely are
but in any event it this is a very
troubling issue right now John thank you
very much I should add that John Lampe
is in some ways responsible for that
book responsible for me spending several
years more years than I expected to with
the war criminal
it was John's suggestion when I got the
fellowship here that I that that I
looked at writing something on slobodan
milosevic
and so I would very much like to thank
you for that for that guidance and and
your advice I think the questions are
good the the it is true it he's
reinventing once again slow velocity
she's reinventing himself and it does
and he is showing himself that he's
still did still dangerous I think that
whether the two Pacific questions I
think that eventually some of his
lieutenants you know there are after all
still several indicted war criminals
still at large in Belgrade
I believe eventually all of those will
end up in The Hague I think eventually
sufficient pressure will be brought
maybe I maybe this is too optimistic but
I eventually think they will the there
are plenty of other people who are not
indicted
although meant some of the men are
mentioned in indictments who could
provide evidence for instance yo Viets
astonish each I don't understand why
he's not been indicted but he was
yogurts astonish each was much loved and
I'm a loss which chief of secret police
from about I think from 1989 until 1988
and he was responsible for much for
organizing a lot of the evil deeds he
could testify very persuasively and and
I never have been made to do that I know
it but if if he could do that it would
be very persuasive to the Serbian people
as well
the your second question like I also
observed what you what you the
phenomenon you you described and in
troubled by it I was in I was in cost of
an install grade on June twenty eighth
nineteen last year when he left for the
Hague and it was it was pretty yeah it
was June twenty eighth once again vetoed
on is another another memorable day in
serve history whether it's a it's a
catastrophe
or a triumph remains to be seen but it
was struck by the by the by the
indifference with which most serves that
greeted the event before there had been
a lot of concern that
if philosophy was sent to the Hague
there would be justice massive
outpouring of resentment and
demonstrations and the the new
government and put in place after then
after the upheaval would be weakened or
maybe even brought down that just turned
to be got to be totally misplaced you
know there were that that evening there
was a crowd of you know the usual crowd
four or five thousand primarily elderly
demonstrators kind of yelling and
chanting slogans and after a while they
were dispersed and went home after I
think roughing up a couple of Western
journalists and breaking a couple
windows they went home and that was it
but it what is happening now I think is
troubling and then the the Milosevic the
this this he has the right obviously to
conduct his own defense and that it is
going to be a public trial but it is it
is I think having a troubling impact in
Serbia I don't think it's gonna mean the
loss which is gonna be convicted I think
I mean the evidence is overwhelming he's
not going to escape but the the impact
of this trial remains to be seen and
that's one reason why I said what I did
about Truth and Reconciliation
commissions I mean one reason you have
this reaction in Serbia is is that the
Serbian people have not confronted
honestly what was done in their name and
by them in the 1990s and they need to do
that before they can get on with
building a future now that doesn't mean
that they were the Serbs were the only
guilty ones and that's why I said it has
to be a regional process but I think
this is the only way to avoid the danger
that you were pointing quite aptly
pointing out John um I think what we
have this gentleman and that book
gentlemen but I may if I may just let me
insert my question because I think it
follows on nicely with after John's and
that is to get you to talk a little bit
about what's happening in Kosovo and in
part since you were just there
week or so though and in part to get
your sense of how in Kosovo they view
the process of The Hague Tribunal since
Kosovo that's what's actually on the
agenda now Bosnia will follow we know
there's been new developments there
there's a new UN UNMIK director or High
Representative a there is a new
government after four months of
wrangling and just to get your sense of
what there is also to give another a
pitch here if you don't mind very
briefly we have outside several copies
of an article Lewis is just done in the
journal problems of post communism on
Kosovo the key to Balkan stability and
that's available outside you can get his
views on that okay let me on Kosovo
briefly first on the trial obviously
kosovo albanians
we're watching the trial is that as it
unfolded on their television screens in
in fascination and then and then in in
in dismay and and horror almost and they
were obviously kosovo albanians were
pleased on the one hand to see Milosevic
in the dock this man who had done so
much to torment their people in their
nation on the other hand they were they
their reaction was sort of the reverse
of what it was in in Belgrade they were
they were appalled at how how he was
able to that this is how he was able to
cast doubt on witnesses how he was how
he was able to deny credibility he he
turned out to be a pretty effective
lawyer at least so far and maybe in part
because the it seems to me some of the
witnesses were not very well prepared as
well but but some of the some of the
witnesses and including some very
prominent Kosovo Albania nickel figures
Milosevic just kind of demolished and in
part because there I think there were
poor witnesses they were called to
testify about the things that Milosevic
and others had done in Serbia are in in
Kosovo in the 1980s
this one of one of the witnesses makalu
bakkali the is the Communist Party chief
up to 1981 and he left after 1981 and so
Milazzo which was quite quite successful
able to show that malama bacala's
testimony was in fact second hand why
the hey tribunal didn't say if they
wanted to do that I'm not quite sure I
understand I'm not a lawyer I don't
understand why they felt they had to get
that kind of information on the record
of the trial but if they did they could
have summoned Azam Flossie to the
tribunal isin velocity was the head of
the Communist Party in cost of Oh in the
80s he was deposed by Milosevic he was
jailed by Milosevic I'm philosophy as a
friend of mine I saw him in Kosovo two
weeks ago he he said no one and the
Tribunal has contacted him he says he
has chapter and verse he has documents
than willing to share but no one's
contacted him so you know they try they
aim for the initial impact of the
tribunal in cost of I was not very not
very good either
turning to Kosovo the political process
in a way I would I would say that the
the international community which rule
which governs Kosovo really hasn't
thinks this knows what it wants to do
but doesn't have a clue about what it
wants it wants what it wants to do now
but doesn't have a clue about what it
wants to do with Kosovo in the future
the cost of Albanians
know exactly were they what they want to
do in the future but they don't have a
clue about how to get there the
situation remains in some ways frozen
all cost of Albanians continue to want
independence all of the cost of a Serb
minority says if that happens we will
leave there's a new government formed at
long last formed on the basis of
compromise I think that government will
be able to sort of begin the process of
allowing the people of Kosovo to start
governing themselves democratically and
and to gain greater power
take-take-take step-by-step more
authority from the the international
community
but the question of the future remains
out there and it underlies a lot there's
a the the absence of clarity about
Kosovo's future continues to impede
progress in many many areas and there's
also a real economic problem the
international community in Kosovo came
in thinking that whether they needed to
it was a classic post-conflict situation
they needed to rebuild a destroyed
community and that was part of and they
did some of that but they also needed to
treat it as a transition economy they
needed also to manage the process of
economic reform and privatization they
have done zip there they've done nothing
virtually nothing and that needs to be
done because you know the current across
the albanians people of native
entrepreneurial talent and people with a
wealthy diaspora some of their wealth
may be wouldn't you know wouldn't want
to look too deeply into sources of some
of it but they're bringing money into
the province they're doing rebuilding in
a small scale building a small business
economy but nothing above that's being
done and and what this is doing is
driving all economic activity into the
gray economy so that's a problem there's
no there there are it's it's relatively
quiet in Kosovo there has been some
progress but you know there needs we
need to start thinking about Kosovo's
future within the region there are three
people with questions the gentleman here
you and then the jack Seymour so those
those will be the next three I can
yellow it's one of the foreign service
colleagues that Lois referred to earlier
first of all Louie congratulations on
your excellent work I wanted to pick up
though you said that there was no
smoking gun no paper trail my question
is could you talk a little bit more
about his style of leadership who did
the dirty work how did he engage them
and how did it all unfold right
thank you Ken you know I should be I
suppose be more accurate there is no
smoking gun that I'm aware of and you
know there
where times in my career I would have
had access I think had such the thing
existed but not now obviously there may
I mean I hope there is a smoking gun I
mean I hope at some point that Hague
Tribunal is going to sort of unveil you
know the crown jewels of their case and
but I don't think it does exist he was
always very careful his style of rule
was one number one he was a user and a
manipulator of people he would get
others to do his do dirty work and then
having having used them he would
dispense with them even in the beginning
fire them toward the end of his rule
occasionally some people would die but
or be jailed and he was very good at and
using indirect methods I mean the
paramilitaries for example the
paramilitaries were they were created
there where they were created out of the
the dregs of the Belgrade and Serbian
underworld including out of soccer
hooligans one in one case and they they
were created with the direct assistance
of the Serbian police and some of the
participants have later talked about the
assistance they got but Milosevic was
always very careful to keep his hands
off he he with the exception of Archon
for some and for some reason he Archon
he liked Archon and he praised Archon
public in several occasions that I guess
that was his style he he he would extend
he gave orders they were oral orders and
they might be not do the direct they
might not be direct orders to the person
actually doing it but to someone else he
was cut out to tell someone else to do
it to tell someone else to do it so that
that's kind of a general answer and it's
best maybe the best I can do at this
stage al Millikan Washington independent
writers
as a leader and particularly as a leader
of warriors the Serbs who as a people
seem to have suffered and shed blood
disproportionately throughout the 20th
century I'm wondering how well do you
think Milazzo vets saw the dangers of
Islamic terrorism and aggression and the
desire to impose Islamic law on all and
also does the legacy of Nazi aggression
still live on with Milosevic and the
Serbs as a people I've read that Serbs
fiercely resisted Hitler as strongly as
any people did but do you think this was
true or is this just mythologies that
has emerged from certain his historical
well the last question I mean you know
the the Hyuga slavi and world war ii was
suffered a civil war at the same time it
suffered a resistance movement a really
several resistance movements against the
german and other fascist occupiers and
you know the serbs the serbs were part
of both a partisan resistance movement
and also of a nationalist resistant
movement called the Chetniks but there
were plenty of other other out all of
the other peoples of Yugoslavia were
also part of that to a greater or lesser
degree maybe with the the kosovo
albanians
I really didn't play much role there I
don't think that the I mean I don't
think that the legacy of world war ii
was particularly important it did play a
little bit of role in the industry
thought oh gee of victimhood that the
serbs built up for themselves serbs were
as this serves in world war ii were the
victims of a very brutal campaign of i
guess what we would call ethnic
cleansing by the fascist douche dashi in
world war ii there's no question about
that although there's a fierce arguments
about how many were killed
and that that figured in this or the
national accusations of guilt and
numbers and that kind of thing figured
in the nationalist euphoria and the
nationalist people of the late 1980s but
that kind of that that's pretty much
faded away I guess all it'll never go
away completely and your first question
you know I think yeah I think Milosevic
in genuinely disliked cost of he
disliked Albanians he's not unique in
that I think that and by and large the
the notion of ancient ethnic animosities
although there is something to it
obviously it was often used as an excuse
for foreign for for not intervention I
do think though that kind of the Serb
versus Albanian is is an example of
ancient ethnic animosity that is true
and you know vilasa [ __ ] often refer to
Alabamians and kind of racist terms he
was not alone in that and then you could
hear that from any other Serbs and
Albanians with yeah I think so
most which was not you could you could
hear sort of is if you will Islamic
slurs easy I mean I member once it's
worth right at the end of Dayton he said
it was all over or just about over and
he said is toward the end he said well
at least now you Americans will know
what it's like to live with Moslems you
know but I don't think that was the
driving force I think it was it was not
religion was a factor I was not the
major factor in that war and in those
wars I think is working I'm Jacques
Seymour I'm with the international
foundation for election systems and
Louis you talked about or you mentioned
Kosovo being the key to stability in the
in the Balkans and I'd like to you did
comment a little bit about this and I'd
like to explore the way ahead and I have
with me a colleague a colleague Pauline
deal who is
worked with the elections administration
in Kosovo and has some views about the
difficulties on the ground created by
the uncertainty politically and also
about ways in which serves and Albanians
have actually worked reasonably well
together in setting up municipal
election commissions and this kind of
thing and would like to just turn the
mic to her and then explore the general
question of the way ahead I mean yes I
have to question concerning cristóbal
they are short about the Security
Council resolution 1244 it's mentioned
there just because it I notice how much
ambiguity it creates among the
comprehension of Albanians most mostly
Kosovar Albanians regarding this
resolution so it puts Kosovo its mention
it keeps Kosovo territory as belonging
to Yugoslavia it never mentions Serbia
so the Albanians believe that and do
hope and follow very closely the
evolution of potential referendum in
Macedonian Montenegro thinking that if
the Federation blows out they will be
free on their own and that nobody never
corrected that and nobody there's no
official document to remind them that
they are part of historically they are
part of a country named Serbia whether
they like it or not so that will that
will bring them to think about more
negotiations with Serbia which are not
they're not even the political leaders
are not ready to do now the other point
is this
constitutional framework that was signed
by the second srs G which creates the
position of president of Kosovo
if Kosovo is a province
how can Kosovo has had a president that
sends strange messages to both to all
communities there mainly to Serbs and
Albanians and that does not bring the
lead the Albanians very ready to
negotiate anything with the Serbs
because they are above they are above
this and they have the thing they do
have the full support of international
community in that sense would be for any
true negotiations between Kosovo and and
they'll trade so I would like to to hear
you hear your thoughts about this sure
well thank you I'll try to respond to
some of the points you've raised first I
was UN Security Council 1244 is very
ambiguous you know III have read it many
many times and and I don't understand
and that's not by accident it's a
process it's a product of a torturous
negotiation first with between Milosevic
and the coalition and then in New York
and you know it is unclear and even
internally contradictory so the fact
that the Albanians don't understand it
it's not surprising second 1244 you seem
to be implying that 1244 is an endpoint
it's not it's a transition it's at a
it's an interim arrangement for Kosovo
at some point twelve one of the things
1244 does say is there will be a process
under put underway for a I forget the
exact words permanent settlement or
something like that
and that's what I was referring to that
needs to start happening it doesn't you
don't need to get a need you should not
try to get a permanent settlement now
but you need to start preparing a
roadmap for getting there
the I will also say just sort of get off
my chest something about the use of the
word you Slavia the so called
Federal Republic of Yugoslavia is a
fraud it's a it never existed and it
doesn't exist now the country of
Yugoslavia was an honourable country a
decent place not without his problems as
we obviously see but many people
including myself lived in it and and
we're fond of it it came to an end in
1991 there is no long or anything called
Yugoslavia that in reality exists the
Federal Republic of Yugoslavia it was a
creation of Milosevic in 1992 it never
functioned it was it didn't function the
way it was supposed to even then it was
always dominated by him and him alone
his the artificial nature of it was
shown when he to his later regret sort
of just arbitrarily changed the
constitution to allow him to run for
president and when he didn't need to and
then he lost
you know there's middle that's a really
unfortunate that that we continue to to
use that concept I know we will but it
has caused a lot of a lot of problems in
our thinking and in the way we approach
that view there is no longer any such
thing as Yugoslavia
there's Serbia that exists and always
will
and there's Montenegro inand and maybe
they'll be United maybe they won't I
don't know
with respect to the president
Ibrahim Raghava is the president of
Kosovo it's legally elected president
Kosovo will never again be part of
Serbia whatever happens it's never going
to be part of Serbia we don't know what
it will be the I think that that is I
think that the the fact that we have to
discuss this is an example of how the
the lack of clarity confuses the way
ahead and really if it continues long or
could get dangerous you know that the
the cost of Oh Albanians will never
again be ruled by Belgrade never and
it's time for our all concerned to
acknowledge that and start to deal with
the consequences bad and good and
they're both and they you can deal with
it it's not it's not an impossible thing
to deal salute do we devise solutions
for but you have to you have to deal
with it honestly I think we have time
for one more question bill thanks Bill
Hill currently here at the Wilson Center
first of all congratulations on your
book looked forward to that when I was
here with you a few years ago and it's
gonna be good to read it now you say
1244 is is not an endpoint if I could
push you then to say what do you think
is the logical logical and sustainable
endpoint you say most Kosovo Kosovo
Albanians favor independence is this a
viable solution and in particular in
your recent observations to what extent
do you find advocates there or elsewhere
of a greater Albania or a unification of
Albanian populations in the neighboring
states those are all very important
questions try to answer them briefly let
me let me just answer the last one first
because I remember I'll remember it
greater Albania I think that you know
that's been that has been one of the one
of the international bugbears if you
will about about the Balkans and and and
there and Kosta though the fear that if
Kosovo becomes independent it it'll be
just a Waystation on to uniting with
Albania and there'll be a greater
Albania and will be viewed as
destabilizing I'm not sure that would be
destabilizing but I do think that that's
not an immediate danger if you talk to
Kosovo Albanians they you know they say
in is this a danger if you become
independent will you become a greater
Albanians Oh greater Albania perish the
thought
how could we even dream of such a thing
I mean they learned the language they
know what to say I think I blew them
pretty much at their word I don't
believe in fact that it's it's that
they're lying or at a decision I don't
think that if Causton we became
independent or the next day they would
seek union with Albania there are there
are differences between those two
communities the cost of Albanian
community and the Albanian community of
Albania proper are historically and
culturally in many ways very different
the cost of Albanian community is much
closer to the Albanian community in
Macedonia much closer I do think also
that what you is definitely true over
the in recent years ticking last two or
three years you have seen a greater and
more emerging sense of a community of
Albanian people's the you know Albanians
who during the Cold War were separated
into several different era states
virtually at times for medically sealed
off one from another are in fact more
and more coming to see themselves as one
community I think that's also true I
don't think there would be an immediate
drive for political Union in the decades
ahead
who could say I wouldn't I don't say you
could rule that out the the issue of
well I guess the first question was
really kind of what what are the range
of options for cost of those future in a
way
12:44 is silent on what any of those
it's completely silent on what those
options are and I think the ones on the
table or everything from going back to
being a province of Serbia with autonomy
to being some kind of a republic or an
equal entity within say the Federal
Republic of Yugoslavia or some some
music some new such entity to to a
partition of Kosovo to an independent
cost of awareness existing borders in
fact I think sort of the process of time
and the reality of events on the ground
is narrowing down the options to two
basically two one is is what I think is
the most is the best the most realistic
is an independent Kosovo within its
current borders but one in which the
there is a continued international
oversight role to ensure democracy human
rights etc and one in which the this
independent entity of Kosovo is embedded
in a great and regional ties so that the
borders are completely transparent
people can move across the border
without a passport goods and ideas can
flow so that the Serbs who choose to
remain in this Kosovo would have local
autonomy you would have to have there
are a number of Serbian monuments
ancient monuments in Kosovo
the shrines of Groton eats the destiny
and Pech would probably would have to
have extra territorial status would put
a small Serbian guard force the these
are things that help Albanians
if you talk to the few Albanians who are
thinking and in the future some of them
are willing to acknowledge these kind of
things
if only of course in the context of
their preferred option which is an
independent state you know the other
option which may fall may out may happen
more or less perforce is a partition
cost the most smaller as it is it's
about the size of Connecticut is is in
fact partitioned the northern part of
Kosovo is is virtually completely
inhabited by by Serbs it was almost
always that way
the few Serbs that did used to live in
the North had been driven I mean
Albanians that used to live in the north
had been driven out the city of Mitra
Viets in the middle is it is a divided
city it's like a New Berlin if you go up
there there's a bridge across the ebar
River barbed wire at both ends guarded
by French troops and you walk across it
you feel like you're you're walking
across checkpoint charlie and in some
ways you are working yeah and the end of
this is essence one of the great
failures of the international community
one I mean there's several failures I
mean we failed to protect the Serbian
population against the predictable
revenge attacks of the Albanian
population as they came flooding back
after having been exposed to Serbian
attacks the International may have
failed to protect them the international
community failed to prevent and in some
ways India is complicit in this division
of Kosovo which is enforced by K 4 and
which K 4 is done nothing virtually to
overcome I have over the years written
several things about what ought to be
done to overcome that I think now it's
almost gonna be impossible it's become a
reality on the ground there is not the
will military or political will to
tackle it you're gonna have even if you
Kosovo does become independent within
its existing borders these sir these
problems
they serve regions are going to have to
be given considerable autonomy so that I
guess that's the range of the options
they are well the owner argument against
partition is that it would could set off
some similar efforts elsewhere in the
region the argument being that you know
if if the Serbs of northern Kosovo can
be separated off from Kosovo and join
Serbia why can't why can't the Serbs of
the Republika Srpska and Bosnia do that
or why can't the Albanians then of
Macedonia separate off and that so that
is a danger that's one of the dangers of
partition there is no option out there
that's good
there's no good option for cost of those
future there are only least bad options
I happen to think that independence is
the least bad option but it may not be
the way it is out well thank you look
before I close let me make a few want
announcement that may be of interest to
you I might also say by the way though
that I don't think there's ever been any
good options even Bosnia at all this
either it's always been a difficult road
to hoe all the way not next week but the
week after we will host two films of
direct interest to you here two
documentaries from very different
perspectives the first one will be on -
this is not by the way in our normal
schedule which is why I'm telling you
about this it's it but you can access it
on our website on Tuesday the 19th there
will be a showing of a documentary on
bringing down a dictator which is the
story of the September October events of
2000 directed by Steven York narrated by
Martin Sheen it will be shown on PBS
later this month or next that will be
five to seven thirty in this room on
march 19th on March 22nd that's Tuesday
more Scientifics is me Friday March 22nd
and an entirely different film
Yugoslavia the avoidable war will be
shown directed by George Balch Daanish
which purports to show that nor to try
to rectify
a perceived imbalance in the way the
Western media has portrayed the collapse
of Yugoslavia so that would be two to
five o'clock
March 22nd there'll be no popcorn but a
big screen here and we welcome all of
you to come now I'd like to thank Bluest
for a wonderful presentation here for
coming here for a for a really excellent
book which I heartily recommend to all
of you it goes very quickly and it gives
a real insight into this man and and
what he's done I think which is as I
said at the beginning I think some of
the other books focused on other aspects
but this one really focuses on Milosevic
the man and integrates him into the into
the tragedy of what happened over the
past 12 13 years so Thank You Lewis for
coming here Thank You Marty
Luis Salazar of slobodan milosevic and
the destruction of Yugoslavia it's
published by Duke University Press visit
Duke you
coming up report from ground zero